uh now the theory is if you read
material that is always a little bit
difficult for you
uh perhaps initially you have a very
short lesson with a vocabulary list or
something
and gradually you you deal with material
that has a small number of new words and
gradually by reading
extensively and by listening you will
eventually acquire the language it isn't
quite that simple in reality
because if you are constantly dealing
with material that has only a few
unknown words you will take forever to
learn the language so you have to at
least in my experience i try to speed
things up
so i will
of course in the old days i would deal
with with readers where there was a
vocabulary list the difficulty is if you
review a vocabulary list before reading
something essentially you don't remember
much
in fact there's research that shows
if two groups of students one group
knows what the story is about has read
it in english or something
and the other group is given a
vocabulary list it's the first group
those who are familiar with the subject
matter that will understand more
reviewing a vocabulary list ahead of
reading something has very little impact
on our comprehension
so
i've always said the sort of a major
revolution has been reading online or on
your ipad with access to an online
dictionary
you can quickly look something up it
doesn't tell you the full meaning of the
word it may even give you a
slightly erroneous sense of what the
word
means but in most cases it allows you to
get through the content